hey guys so you have been sending in
your questions to me for the past couple
of weeks about interviews and I'm going
to be going through an answering them
now but before I do I've got a couple of
things I'd like to point out one these
are my opinions they do not represent
those at the university some Peters
college or the physics department these
are just my answers to these questions -
there's already a lot of information
available online about interviews and in
particular I recommend you check out the
Central Oxford website which is OAC UK
and College websites and departmental
websites but also the student real calm
as you have a lot of people logging on
and telling you about their interview
experience what kind of questions they
were asked their experiences over the
couple days there in Oxford which is a
valuable resource to check out three if
you want subject specific advice then I
recommend you check out my colleges
YouTube channel which is SPC Oxford on
there we have interviews with people
doing a range of subjects and in those
interviews they talk about their
recommendations for how to prepare for
interviews and just generally what
advice they would give to somebody who's
thinking of applying so SPC Oxford check
those out which I highly recommend you
do there a lot of them are very
informative
particularly the one for medicine just
done by a very good friend of mine and
he gives some very good advice right now
that's over and done with let's get on
and answer the questions this videos
gonna be split into two sections the
main section is going to be general
questions about interviews and then the
second section is going to be physics
specific questions I do physics and a
lot of people who are asking questions
were asking about the physics course but
I'm gonna be putting that in a little
second section at the end of the video
how did you prepare for your interview /
what do you think is the best way to
prepare I think the best way to prepare
for an interview is to get mock
interviews if at all possible so when I
was preparing for my interview I had a
mock interview with my maths teacher and
what mock interview with my physics
teacher now that I have been to
experience at as far as I know neither
of which have done another spurge
interview but they knew the former and
they knew the kind of questions to us
it's extremely valuable just to get
basic mistakes out of the way and just
so you kind of get used to a slightly
more formal setting in which to do well
slam of almost setting in which to talk
about your subject I guess that's my
first advice my second advice would be
to try and get as much information as
possible about the kind of questions you
can be expected to answer so a good
resource for that is the student room
or alternatively you can look at my
videos on my channel about my physics
interview questions now I should stress
about this the idea is not to memorize
answers of our questions or even to
memorize a set sort of way of answering
the question the point is to get used to
the style of question and to realize
that the important thing is not getting
the answer correct but to explain how
you're thinking and to look at these
questions that you've been given you
know the timid that other people have
been given that you've looked up and say
right well if I was to answer that I
would say this then this than this but
maybe not this because I'm just talk out
loud this is just practice talking
though just to emphasize again the idea
is not to memorize the answer that there
is to get used to the style of question
and to practice the style of answering
the one I really started to comprehend
is the why Oxford question I mean if you
give too little info do you see one
informs a naive it too much info you'll
probably could say something that isn't
true or indeed say too much conceit
Millie again how do you answer that it's
not a question that you should really be
too worried about to be honest I was
asked the White House for the question I
think twice they maybe just once it was
five years ago and it was a throwaway
question at the start of interview they
weren't really interested in my response
it was something really to break the ice
into to start the conversation what I
said which I think it's a reasonable
answer
is that I knew that I wanted the best
education experience possible
I knew that Oxford has a very high good
reputation for teaching has fantastic
resources disposal such as libraries the
tutorial system in particular is a great
advantage because it means that I get
one more or term one teaching with
fantastic academic minds in the subject
and it just means I'm going to get a
better education than anyone else and
that's what I'm interested in and also
there are other advantages like I
visited the city liked it I really liked
the idea of the collegiate system it's
good for sport that kind of stuff it's
not saying that you should be too
stressed about because it's not a
question that I'm going to be basing
whether you get in or not um I don't
think I should Clara I'm a scientist
this is true certainly for science
subjects I cannot say for a hundred
percent that it's true for humanities
subjects but from talking to other
people I don't think it's that anywhere
near as important as the academic
questions interviews fun scary awkward
is anyone in the reef making friends can
you get you through basically what you
did there for the whole time you either
fun scary or awkward um a bit of all of
them to be honest I'm not so much
awkward and definitely scarier points
but the whole experience was fun
actually because when you're they're
friends of you you're there with
everybody else's convenience fee for
that subject and it's a chance to meet
people that are really passionate and
interested in a subject that you're
really passionate and interested about
and that wasn't something I'd
experienced too much at that point there
are a couple of people in my school that
were in physics and I really liked it
but to be surrounded by people that you
know that was what they wanted to do at
university level was something here and
it was great to meet people like that
with all these shared interests plus the
whole experience is kind of fun so to
say what I did when I was there I got
dropped off my my parents get signed in
at the lodge in the College taken out to
my room chairman woods lyndshane where
the chasey I was pointed out that
there's a notice board
you check the notice board which will
tell you when your interviews are where
they are and when you can go home so
they'll post on the notice board you can
definitely go home now because some
people have kept back for extra
interviews and stuff like that but once
that was out the way obviously there
were the interviews to be done but
there's a lot of time sat in the JCR and
just talking to people focus I tried
meeting these people with similar
interests which is really cool in the
evening that I was there we watched film
we were we were taking turns to point
out scientific inaccuracies in
Armageddon which to be honest is not
hard and we also did a pop quiz which is
fun but yeah there's no denying that
somebody to be process is a little bit
scary because you know what at least you
think you knows that at this point this
is one of the most important things
you've done in your life and you you're
so terrified of messing up and in a way
that's the worst thing you could think
because the trick to doing well in
interviews is to relax and not
concentrate on how important this is for
you because if you're stressed and if
you're all tensed up you're never going
to perform at your best the way to
perform your best is to be relaxed and
just to explain the way you think
clearly and logically and it's difficult
to do that if you're very stressed so
that's that's the number one thing and
that was actually what the interview how
was there to do that that's try and calm
me down maybe was comfortable as
possible well ultimately they're never
gonna make the process completely
stress-free but they did a really good
job of doing that it means me did they
expect you to have done your own
independent work of your subject today
question ishow the subject and what time
were they held in ie for whatever also
other multiple interviews ok so there's
quite a few questions there starting
with the last one all the multiple
interviews yes there are almost
everybody will have at least two
interviews anything between two and six
sometimes more it depends if you are
held back for more interviews which is
not necessarily a bad thing you can you
not necessarily a good thing it's
something that you really shouldn't read
into too much if you are given extra
interviews because there's no where
tangle it means and equally if you're
only allocated two interviews don't
think that's a bad thing that they don't
want to talk to you sometimes it's just
done to practice for instance I think
chemistry it's and pieces they do to
interview substandard as for what turn
they're held in they're reasonably for
more it's not an informal chat over a
table or something like that it is
reasonably for but not excessively so
when I did my interviews it was two
professors or one professor and a
postdoc I think it just sat across a
table and given me these problems and
sometimes I have a piece of paper to you
know just Google diagrams you know my
argument and it wasn't like we were sat
on opposite sides of agree whether
you're the great vast chasm between us
or something like some people seem to
have this impression you're gonna be
facing like four professors or something
and then there's one sharing the middle
of the room my experience not like that
I can't say that it won't be like that
but I'm pretty sure it won't be and
lastly do they expect you to have done
your own research into subject they
won't expect it they will expect you to
have taken your understanding of it
beyond the syllabus in the for example
for physics I've read New Scientist I
keep up to date in the news in the
physics for what I've read books like
you know in such as Schrodinger's cat
and I look at the universe and things
like that which definitely take physics
beyond the yellow syllabus but I
wouldn't classes individual research if
you do have the opportunity to do
individual research then they will love
it that's a fantastic thing to be able
to do it's a great thing to be able to
talk about potentially an interview if
you put on your personal
they'll probably pick you up and asking
questions about so not expected but if
you can do it it's a great bonus I've
heard in the Oxford website that for
overseas students who would not probably
be in a situation to attend an interview
in Oxford an interview will be done
through phone or Skype
you also mentioned those interviews are
not guaranteed is it better to attend an
interview in person now there's no
guarantee that you'd be able to get an
interview via Skype on the phone though
I don't think I've heard of anybody
being denied one I've as far as I know
and I'd like to stress that I am NOT an
expert in this I am just an
undergraduate who's gone through in twos
and is currently helping with interviews
and is interested in access as far as I
know it's very likely that you'll be
given an interview via skype or effort
and colleges put a slide rooms for a day
you know what they'll do those kind of
interviews is it better to attend an
interview in person I would say yes if
at all possible because it I suppose on
one level it shows that you're a bit
more committed that you wanted to be
they didn't just want to do the easy
thing into a bias code though obviously
for many people that's just gonna be
impossible sort of logistical or
financially but if at all possible do
try and come see interview because it
means that you can give a better account
of yourself you can give more an
impression of your feelings on the
subject and and them hopefully how
passionate you are about the subject
which isn't the easiest thing to do via
the phone line and also it makes things
like do questions or say bye with
diagrams or whatever they can ask those
kind of questions I think those are
probably more instructive they'll do
when you can show you're working for
something like maths or physics for
instance so yeah if you can come to the
interview do try to but it isn't gonna
be possible all the time what should I
wear for the interview now the official
Oscar guideline is the issue where
whatever makes you feel comfortable and
that is definitely true what I off mind
who was a lounge suit you notice to the
court suit and I think most people who
were taking interviews also did the same
helping up with interviews this time
some Peters people seem to be more
relaxed and wearing for the guys if not
a suit which quite lot of people still
do that is pair smart trousers and a
shirt for a girls and like a pencil
shirt and white blouse or you know
something I don't I don't know if girls
clothing but something that's small the
kind of thing I guess you'd wear to an
office maybe but the important thing is
as I was they to be comfortable they are
not going to judge
based on what your time with
interviewing I'd recommend not turning
up in something completely casual like
baggy jeans and a hoodie or something
because much as they're not gonna judge
your performance at subject based on
what you wear is the kind of thing that
can form a subconscious impression on
people so I would recommend that you
dress smart and for the guys that means
suit for the girls that means yeah the
kind of kind of office where I guess do
you get an interview before the offer or
vice versa then application to colleges
so the order goes a UK application
turning up for interviews possibly with
subject specific tests in between
finding out result of interview and
being given an offer and lastly in this
section for all the people asking about
medicine highly recommend you check out
the interview with medical students on
the SPC Oxford YouTube channel I really
do because it's a fantastic interview it
gives you a great insight into life a
medical student and also my friend Joe
gives some really good advice about
applying so not to move on to the
physics little subsection of the video
if you want to study a mathematical
subject such as engineering physics or
comm Sookie with the interview is quiz
you into why you drop further maths at a
s and would not do a to further math to
make you seem like a weaker candidate
than one who has done a s further maths
that you only know to vote in a short if
you can do further maths to a to
definitely definitely do because for the
first thing a lot of people who'll be
applying for these courses will have
further maths and it will make you a
candidate because of the second point
which is that the course is here in the
scientific subjects like physics and
Madison and comes care stuff like that I
incredibly mathematically based so
physics is essentially just a master's
degree with application so we're not
doing further maths you're not only
putting yourself at a disadvantage while
applying but also putting yourself at a
disadvantage whilst on the course so if
at all possible I really really
recommend that you do you do it way to
is the kind of thing they could ask you
values though no the first thing they
probably would attempt to interview
question they're not a likely one how
much will be about your personal
statement and how much about you
delivering the goose I like that phrase
is there a math / physics questions but
are there any questions about current
events in the physics world that are not
mentioned in your personal statement do
think spacing out any particularly
obscure piece of physics or is it just
mainstream general a level / basic Cosmo
that's a fun question okay so how much
will be about your personal statement
and how much about delivering the goods
probably my new favorite phrase mostly
all about delivering the goods I had a I
had a whole interview about my personal
statement that was because I didn't have
a practical workbook which and whole
other interview was meant to be based on
in all the other interviews I wasn't
taught quizzed on my personal statement
at all in fact I can't remember who it
was I think it was a mathematician who
asked his tutors what did you think of
my personal statements once he got in
and they just went oh we didn't read
them so then I'm not I'm not saying that
the personal Saints are not important I
was one particular case but the
interviews are all about your ability to
do the subject for physics and one of my
friends was actually explicitly told
that when they applied to Keeble college
it's all about your ability to do maths
go to demonstrate the way that you think
so your personal statement is gonna be
variable of other universities with not
so much when you're applying here is
there a maths physics question split yes
well I had one in Jesus College about
maths one interview in Jesus College
about physics and then I had one
interview it's and Peter's which was my
mix of the two and the questions in that
interview would work quite clearly
delineated between physics and maths it
wrapped as a university level Ashley
there's very little distinction between
the two but at interviews yes there will
be a sort of cluster or whole interview
on maths questions and the same for
physics questions are there any
questions about sort of events and the
physics well I didn't have any although
in one of my interviews they asked me a
question about telescopes and they
mentioned oh no no I think I brought it
up actually about this the extremely
large telescope which was being
constructed I think at that point in
South America we wished there was still
an idle distraction for them for about
five seconds I didn't get asked any
questions about it it's not the kind of
thing which I'd expect anybody really to
be lost any questions about they're not
going to expect you to keep up to date
with the latest publications in nature
or anything like that and lastly do they
expect you to know any particular
obscure piece of knowledge was it just
mainstream physics it is just mainstream
physics now the typical weighted into
your work is that they will take
is basic physics that you will know from
a s and then apply it to an unusual
situation or give you a new piece of
information ask you to combine it with
the young your basic endure standing and
then apply that to a situation or
reconcile that new piece of information
with your understanding so the important
thing isn't quite so much what you know
because of your stage of development you
do not know that much about physics no
offense P you know you haven't done a
new greenie yet they're interested not
in what you know but in what you can
potentially know and the way you think
and the way you learn and the way that
they can probe that is to giving you
pieces of information and to see how you
react to it so in that sense I recommend
that you revise your AAS a to serve you
deploy whatever syllabus up to that
point and you are comfortable with all
the material because they will take that
as a relative do seam knowledge but they
will not assume that you know any
particularly obscure think about
Goldstone boson so the Higgs boson or
anything like that other physics
interviews based on knowledge of already
learned topics or pure initiative now I
touched on this in answer to a previous
question but the truthful answer is
there's a little bit of both they will
assume that you know basic physics and
by that I mean some mechanics some
calculus some circuit theory probably
that kind of level of physics and they
will ask you to use your initiative to
apply that basic knowledge to new
situations that you haven't encountered
before or to reconcile that basic
knowledge with new information which
they will give you to use your
information to disprove a particular
thing that they might have so in one
question that I was asked I was asked to
choose between two theories that the
different professors had one of which
was writing one which was wrong and I
had to explain why I chose that
particular Theory the honest answer
would be that it's a little bit of both
that the interview is is based around
your initiative it's based around how
you think not what you know and that's
something which you can only really
improve by practicing going through
interview questions and having practice
interviews like I said at the start of
the video right I think that's it I hope
that this was useful to you guys I
realized that some of you are
interviews at the moment and if that is
the case I wish you very very best of
luck number one piece of advice try and
stay calm don't panic chill you'll do a
lot better okay
socialize with people chill in the JCR
don't spend your whole time stuck in
your in thinking about how scary the
interviews gonna be it probably won't be
and I hope this is useful to people in
the future if you have any further
questions about interviews leave them as
a comment on this video or send me a
message and I will do my best to get
back to you